Broadway just had its most lucrative
season ever raking in over 1.3 billion
dollars in ticket sales or in more
applicable terms like 12% of an Avengers
movie but just because theater is all
about the Hamiltons doesn't mean that
success is translating to community
theater instead actors and local
productions have to pull together
costumes on the cheap giving rise to
tumblers like low-budget beefs and bad
Avenue Q puppets so comedians I will
show you a costume from a community
theater production featured on tumblr
opportunity 50 points I would like you
to answer a question about it first up
an awkward take on Beauty and the Beast
oh that's fun meetings
what has this beast so freaked out Jim
he just realized he wasn't supposed to
on the rug
all right boys yes Kristen he realized
he wasted 50 grand on a theater degree
[Laughter]
James David his boner is peeking through
his pencil oh yes I guess it is that's a
good next everyone's favorite green ogre
Shrek well that's going to paint my
nightmares
what award will this win and famous
least offensive donkey all right I'm not
gonna yell oh man nothing next one a man
playing bottom in A Midsummer Night's
Dream why does he look so pleased with
himself
mrs. Norton he thinks he may actually
lose his virginity at the cast party
all right boy Jim Davis he's proud he
finally found himself one of them Selena
all right boy all right next up a very
realistic production of Camelot as you
can see here comedians what do they do
at the cast party Jim Norton see who is
worthy to pull the dildo out of King
Arthur's ass all right boy Preston this
is the cast party yeah boy
[Applause]
finally Hamilton is in the only show
that's blending hip-hop with Broadway
here's some cool dudes reproduction to
Joseph and the Amazing Technicolor
Dreamcoat
sweetie is what what song are they
busting down Jim the substitute teacher
all right fine
Kristin ah baby got call back yes boy
good day famous my name's Joseph this is
my jacket it is so fresh so so fresh and
so clean
yeah
[Applause]